From the Library of Congress and the Smithsonian National Museum of African American History and Culture.
Good morning.
Today is December 14, 2015.
This is David Cline from the History Department of Virginia Tech, and also working with Southern Oral History Program at the University of North Carolina at Chapel Hill.
I'm here today on the campus of Wesley Theological Seminary with Maynard E. Moore, and I will ask you if you would just introduce yourself, and then we'll have a conversation.
All right. My name is Maynard E. Moore, and I've been in Washington for the last 35 years, so.
Great. So if we could start with just ask you a little bit about where you were born and raised, and we'll talk a little bit about your child.
Well, I was born in Petersburg, Virginia in 1938, which is fairly important as a context for me personally, because it was my.
I was raised in Petersburg, and this is a, this was a Southern town. Still is a Southern town in many important respects.
I had a long history and was the scene of a decisive battle in the Civil War, and it's where the Union troops dug a tunnel under the Confederate works, and ultimately by an accidental trigger.
They were planting dynamite and blew the Confederate works, and it's now a historic site, the crater.
And people in Petersburg never forgot that, and would place that as a prominent event in the history of the town.
It was a commercial center for decades before and after the Civil War, mainly a railhead and switching area for tobacco.
And the economy had been boosted in the early 20th century with the establishment of Fort Lee, Camp Lee → Fort Lee as a quarter master depot for the Army.
So lots of money and people float into the area in World War II when I was growing up.
My family was Methodist. We were members of Washington Street United Methodist Church. There were 10 Methodist churches in the town.
We had a town of 35,000 people, and it was equivalent number of Baptist and other churches, so that was very much part of the life of the town.
All of which was segregated, of course.
My home church has a placard out in front of the church now on the wall.
That marks the spot that says in 1846. This was the site where the Methodist Episcopal Church, South was organized.
And that was when the Methodist churches in the South broke over the issue of slavery from the Methodist church in the north.
And so that placard still stands to mark that occasion.
And this was your home church?
That was my home church. That's where I grew up. And where I felt the call to ministry.
And it was a member of the youth group and subsequently participated in Methodist Student Movement and the district and then was elected to state-wide office in Methodist Student Movement when I was a senior in high school.
So Maynard, in your childhood growing up in Petersburg in this particular church was the segregation of the time where racial issues talked about either at home or in the church?
Nobody addressed racial issues probably by design unspoken.
And for the most part during those years I was asleep.
It was not an issue on my radar screen nor with my family. It was the way of life.
We lived on one of the main cross streets in town.
And the way the town was organized and as typical of most southern towns the cross streets were those that were occupied by the black population.
So we had black folks in our neighborhoods, so to speak, but not on the main streets.
And they were on the cross streets that were less cared for.
But I grew up playing with black kids until it was time to go to junior high school.
At that point my mother explained to me that they would no longer be welcome in our house.
as had previously been the case. I had always invited my black friends to come in to the house for watch a Howdy Doody show or have cookies in ice cream or you know.
I visited their houses but at the point where we went to junior high school that was no more.
No more interaction. Some of my best buddies among those black kids.